the goal of this video is to understand
how median per-capita income after taxes
has trended in the United States in
comparison to some other countries over
a thirty-year period as a 30 year period
for this chart is from 1980 to 2010 so
for example in this first comparison the
United States is compared against Canada
and you can see at the beginning of this
time period the median per-capita income
after taxes in the United States was
higher than that of Canada but then over
the course of this thirty-year period it
looks like they've gotten pretty close
to each other so you could say that the
rate of increase in Canada over that
period has been higher for this group
and so that's what got them to parity in
Norway we're looking over that same time
period again from 1980 to 2010 and we're
seeing a similar story in Norway there
was actually a fairly large gap between
the median per-capita incomes after
taxes between the two countries in 1980
and that gap has closed now on one level
you might say hey the rate of increase
of median per-capita income after taxes
in Norway is greater but on another
level you could say well even at the end
point someone making that median
per-capita income after taxes in the
United States will still be better off
even at the end of our time period at
2010 and we see that generally true for
all of these countries they all have
steeper curves so a higher rate of
change of but the United States on an
absolute level has stayed higher
although the gap has gotten smaller for
most of these so you could interpret it
either way but it's probably leading to
other questions you might say all right
this is just for that those folks in
that 50th percentile the people in the
middle the median per capita income what
about people at other points in the
distribution what we just saw is for the
median here and you can see the u.s.
curve in this burgundy type color and
then instead of showing the median over
and over again over that time period
it just plots the other countries right
over here so you can see that trend in
Canada at the beginning of the period
the media
per capita income after taxes was lower
than that in the United States and then
it closes the gaps and then we can see
the other countries Norway Netherlands
Britain Sweden so on and so forth and
this is useful because you can see even
though the rate of improvement is deeper
for these other countries at least for
the median you're still better off being
in the United States but the picture
does change a little bit depending on
which countries you look at and which
extreme you look at you can see that for
that fifth percentile there countries
like Germany where if you're in that
fifth percentile you were better off in
1980 and in 2010 relative the United
States but the rate of improvement is
actually similar and I'm speaking in
very rough terms to that of the United
States and then you have countries like
Ireland where at the beginning of the
period you would have been worse off if
you were in the fifth percentile being
in Ireland and at the end of the period
it looks like you are slightly better
off and then we can see that trend for
the 10th percentile 20th percentile so
on and so forth and the benefit of being
in the United States over that time
period and the improvement in inflation
adjusted after-tax income over time
seems to be more dramatic in the United
States as you get to the higher
percentiles when you see this 95th
percentile the United States was already
better off than everyone else in 1980
and the gap between those 95th
percentile has only increased now
there's several takeaways that you could
have from this one is is it the rate of
improvement in some of these other
countries is steeper but on the other
hand for example if we look at in
Ireland or Spain the rate of improvement
is steeper especially for some of the
lower percentiles but folks still have
finished up at an absolute lower level
so even in 2010 you would be better off
being in the United States
another question that some of you might
be asking is why do you see this
phenomenon in the United States that the
rate of growth in inflation adjusted
after-tax income over time seems to be
highest for the upper income folks in
the United States it could be because of
tax policy the u.s. does have relative
to many of these countries a lower
effective highest marginal tax rate
so for the people in the highest incomes
they're paying a lower percentage of
their taxes than people in other
countries even though many of them might
be paying a higher percentage relative
to some of the other income brackets you
could also say that it might not be a
fair comparison the United States is a
much larger economy than most of these
countries the only ones that come even
close the United States out of these
would be Germany but their economy
there's still less than 1/4 the size of
the United States now there could be
other dynamics at play that we talked
about in other videos but it's at least
interesting to know what the data tells
us